hello everyone this is daniel
welcome to another youtube video a
couple of videos ago
i i did a video where i basically solved
and
talked through in detail solving a bunch
of
master level puzzles on chess.com uh
that video was
very well received both on youtube and
on my twitch stream people were asking
me to do another
one of those videos where i walk through
my thought process
and sort of the mental mechanism that
allows me to solve
high-level chest problems and chest
tactics and
i have responded so i will do another
video
where i walk through about five or six
approximately
chess puzzles in the rating range of
2000 to 2300 so sort of expert to master
and i will talk through every one of
those problems
and try to explain how i go about
solving them and perhaps as i usually do
share some tips on tactics improvement
and calculation and puzzle solving in
general
and without further ado let's get
started
[Music]
um now okay so we have a position
here where it's black to move we're down
a piece
so that's observation number one
we're down to piece observation number
two is it's an end game so
clearly something drastic is going to
have to happen here
in order for us to come back from this
the first move that i see is rook d5
check this is a move a lot of people
would just play without thinking
because after the king takes the pawn we
can take the bishop and and you know you
win the bishop back
but it's very important to resist that
initial temptation the problem is
if you go rook t5 king e6 rook t4 well
let's extend that line for a couple
he takes our rook we take his rook and
he takes the pawn and white is actually
up
three puns so the second observation
which doesn't seem as relevant but
actually is
is that white is already up a pawn in
this position he's going to be up two
more
that doesn't actually help the issue but
if we look a little bit more carefully
notice why it's king it's in the center
but it actually doesn't have all that
many escape squares right it can't go
back to e4
e6 is currently covered by the rook and
really rook d5 would be checkmate were
it not for
these two squares that the king can
escape to and black has just the piece
to guard these escape squares
preemptively and the move king f7 here
poses the mate threat rook d5 and
there's actually no defense of that
threat let's unpack that for a second
if he gives us a check on c7 we can
actually just block with the rook
and the exchange of rooks doesn't help
black's still going to be threatening
worth d5
by the same token if after well king f6
would be a pretty interesting move
if after king f7 white goes rook c5
uh then we just go rook t5 and because
our rooks are doubled
um this is still going to be checkmate
so we go king f7
they go rook c7 it's important to go
with this rook i think let's try to
figure out why
yeah because if we go with the other
rook then he can simply bring his other
rook to c1 and this rook is gonna be
pinned
uh to the king so we won't be able to
move it to d5
and okay bishop c5 is a meaningless move
we go rook c5 and the game is over
very good okay uh next position so here
we have um
here we have an interesting situation uh
the
first thing i see is the tension that
that is going on here right there some
diagonal tension and i notice that
black's bishop is x-raying
uh white's queen okay
now the other thing i notice and i've
talked about this at length in previous
videos is undefended pieces you always
have to notice
uh undefended pieces by which i mean
pieces that are literally not protected
by
any other pieces or pawns because they
often factor into uh
a vast majority i would say of of
tactics
at least they play a tangential role in
them uh and i noticed the rook on on c1
here
is undefended so combining these two
observations right the fact that the
bishop x-rays the queen
and the rook on c1 is undefended we
noticed the move rook c8
not you know not a particularly complex
move
now it's harder to understand the
fallout of roxy what
threats does rook c8 create well the
bishop has two defenders and it has two
attackers so it's not like we're
threatening to just take the bishop
twice but
we are threatening two things that
relate to this rook on c1 first of all
we're threatening b5 b5 attacks the
bishop
and if bishop takes on d5 this is after
rook ca then we take on c1 with check
it's very important that that is check
if it wasn't check the bishop would
capture the pawn on e6 and would
actually be a fork against black's queen
so we take the rook with check and then
we recapture white's bishop and we're
just going to be up a rook
so after the move rook ca white's going
to have to do something
to either get the king out of check or
defend the bishop or both and the move
that seems to accomplish both is rook
after c2 right
now if we go b5 that doesn't do anything
because of
well bishop takes his own pawn on d4
yeah bishop takes d5
so um this is where it's very important
to return
to the first observation that might
sound a little bit weird but what often
happens when we're looking at tactics is
okay we notice a move and we try to
understand why we played that move
in this case the rook on c1 is really i
would say the
the root reason that we played with ca
and then we forget about the other thing
we noticed which is the x-ray
you want to keep reminding yourself of
all of the tactical features of the
position
and if we remind ourselves of the x-ray
then after rook c8 rook c2
what i notice is the move rook takes c4
he has to take with a rook and then we
go pawn to b5
and we are in effect pinning his rook
now to the queen
if he moves his rook somewhere we take
the queen if he doesn't we take the rook
with our pawn
and we're gonna remain up a piece if we
calculate a little bit further the only
thing i noticed in that position so to
recap rook aca rook fc2
rook takes c4 rook takes c4 b5 he can
try to move the rook away to c7 with
tempo
um and that is an unpleasant move
because if we take his queen he takes
ours and he's up in exchange
but when there are two queens hanging
and this is a rule that
everybody must remember the first thing
you look for are what's called desperado
sacrifices
i think most of you are probably
familiar with that term that's where you
uh essentially give up your queen for as
much as possible
uh with the knowledge that you're gonna
take his queen after that so if you can
give the queen up at least for a piece
uh that's better than just giving it up
uh scot-free you know just getting
giving it up for free the other thing
you're looking for is checks right if
you can move your queen away with a
check you don't even need a desperado
sacrifice
the king has to move and then you take
the queen and you're up a whole queen
here we do have a desperado sacrifice we
can just take that rook on c7
and uh once he takes our queen then we
take on on b3 and we're up a piece at
the end of the day
uh the only other thing i wanted to
point out here is what happens if rook e
to c8
if rook e to ca then if we repeat the
whole line
b5 rook c7 and we desperado sacrifice
at the very end of that the bishop on e7
is actually going to be undefended
so again undefended pieces play a role
for both sides here we've got to go
rocase8 takes b5
desperado sacrifice notice that if he
would have taken our bishop and counter
desperadoed
we would have taken the rook with check
and and then taken the queen
so here we take the bishop and the game
is over
um okay uh so let's
see what this problem has in store for
us all right
interesting situation the material is
well black is up two pawns actually so
we
kind of need to do something urgently um
what tactical features do i notice here
well there is some you know there's
tension here between the knights we can
take the knight if we want to
and we can win a pawn but since we're
down two pawns and our king is a little
bit flimsy
that doesn't seem to constitute success
i also noticed that black's king is a
little bit flim there's something about
black's king that's
not sitting very well with me right the
f pawn is gone
and the bishop on d3 there's you know
there's a potential check on h7 i know
that doesn't seem to matter right now
the other thing i notice is that the
queen of the rook are in one diagonal
whenever there is a queen and a rook on
the same diagonal
and you even have bishops that is
something you have to notice because
the skewer is one of the most powerful
tactical
uh motifs that in existence you know you
can skewer the queen to the rook and
then you can win
at the very least in exchange um and
again
it's all about combining observations
here we notice the weak king we notice
the queen and the rook on the same
diagonal
so after knight takes c6d takes c6
one thing that really appeals to me is
the move bishop to d6
and this creates an elementary kind of
x-ray well the reason queen takes d6 is
not possible is because of that
rudimentary x-ray idea
we move the bishop away discover check
against the queen and then we take the
queen we have a queen for two pieces
if he doesn't take the bishop and he
moves his queen away
then we take the rook and not only have
we won an exchange after the queen
recaptures or the king recaptures
it it walks right into the frying pan
another x-ray and so we can pick off the
knight then with the move g5
so you might be asking well how did i
sort of
you know how did i know to combine these
two observations well
um that's where my animal brain came in
i mean i just combined them
subconsciously but at the same time
you can sort of try manually to ask
yourself okay
well i see the queen and the rook on the
same diagonal um
can i try to skewer the queen and the
rook how can i do that
and if you ask yourself that you'll
notice the move bishop d6 maybe you'll
think that move is impossible at first
but as i
indicated in past videos you never want
to reject a potentially powerful move
immediately you always want to give it a
chance
so let's execute these moves okay 94 so
that's not a move i anticipated
i think it it makes a whole lot of noise
um
but these moves can be a little bit
annoying so
there's two possible okay so bishop
takes c7
is the trick right they take on d2 with
track and we can't take the knight we
actually have to take the knight
and the problem is solved whoa now this
looks crazy but these problems can
actually be the easiest ones the ones
that look the craziest and i think this
is no exception
what is the first thing i see well black
is down a piece right two bishops
against one knight
and white has these massive pawns so we
clearly are going after white's king
there's no doubt about that
checks captures threats um is the sort
of elementary advice that
is shared and part of the reason that i
sometimes am skeptical about this advice
is because
it's one thing to just say look for
checks captions and threats but
i would modify this and say look for
every check
capture and threat not those that look
logical but literally every single one
if you are going to apply that principle
because what happens is your brain sort
of self-selects and
it assumes subconsciously that certain
moves are not good and that's not good
because
then you defeat the whole purpose of
using this method so um
the other thing we can notice is this a2
pawn if the bishop were gone from a1
well then a1 queen would not only
promote but it would promote checkmate
so the move queen takes a1 check comes
to mind because it's both a capture and
a check
king takes a1 and now we can smoke the
king out of there
the rookie one check if the rook blocks
we we take
with discover check and it's checkmate
in like 50 different ways so the king
has to move away from that
boy is that a lot of arrows on on those
squares and and
as if that was enough we promote a1 and
the hilarious thing is we can actually
make a bishop there
and that will still be checkmate such is
the power of this idea
boom boom okay queen d1 very effective
defensive resource
uh which is refuted by rook takes d1 and
the game is over
very nice okay let's proceed
well wait a second what is going on here
isn't the rook hanging
literally the rook is hanging with check
um black is also but let's not forget to
make the observations black is down a
piece so
i i think this could be a case of move
first think later i mean
i don't see why not take the rook yeah
okay so king f2 this is where we
actually really need to think uh
sometimes just.com does that and i like
it you know sometimes you have to know
to call your opponent's bluff and not to
over complicate things now this seems
like actually a pretty complicated
problem so
prepare to sort of hunker down and get
to the bottom of it
now what does white have now in return
for the exchange we have a rook for a
piece
well i mean white has this beautiful
knight on t6 the king on e7 is weak the
knight on h5 is
clearly very misplaced there's a lot of
things that are going for white
what's going for black in addition for
the exchange is the fact that white's
king is also
it seems to me quite weak right it's on
f2 and the other thing that's going for
us
is the fact that the queen is x-raying
the rook and
it's important here notice my wording
it's not the rook is x-raying the queen
the queen is x-raying the rook
uh because the rook is undefended again
those
darned undefended pieces coming to the
rescue
uh but of course the rook is also
x-raying the queen because
if the bishop comes out yes white might
sacrifice the rook
but there might be problems in relation
to black's king that require
greater attention than the rook on h1 so
even though it's hanging white can use
that as a ploy
to orchestrate an attack against the
king the other thing to notice here is
the rook is hanging
so i've said a whole lot of stuff here
and
what i'm really leading to is i don't
think this is anything extraordinary i
think this is one of those problems
where you just have to find a simple
move
and i think the simple move is just to
take on a3
we take on a3 we prepare something like
rook a2 rook takes c2
and i don't see any good square for the
bishop i mean bishop can go out to p5
um we we take the rook he takes our
bishop that could be actually pretty
unpleasant
um he takes our bishop uh with check and
then if we take with the rook
queen takes d7 check and i forgot to
mention at the beginning of the video
that
you're welcome to follow along with a
real a real board in fact i highly
recommend it if you
if you feel like you're having a trouble
if you're having natural if you're
having trouble visualizing
some of these longer lines so there's
nothing wrong with that at all
um okay so this is actually
kind of an annoying well it is an
annoying problem and it's also an
annoying idea rook takes b it takes a3
bishop b5
uh so what this is telling me is either
i need to calculate that line more
deeply or i'm missing something pretty
simple here so let me think here for a
second
about what it could be and like i always
do and i always say
there's nothing wrong just sitting in
silence for five ten minutes
if you have to and just hunkering down
and trying to get to the bottom of a
position
that's exactly what i'm going to do here
i'm gonna take as much time as i need
think about it and share my thoughts
with you uh
once i have them so here we go okay
and by the way i will just say as i'm
thinking that i do think this is a
problem where they didn't
fully anticipate the difficulty probably
because i'm overthinking it and and
on they did not intend probably the move
is just rook takes a three and the
problem stops there
but i'm not solving this to impress
anybody and say how many i got right in
a row i'm solving this because i want to
learn
i don't want to get better at tactics so
i think that should always be the
mentality not
i want to solve this as quickly as
possible but rather i want to figure out
and get to the bottom of this position
even if
um i know that the problem is going to
end after
you know a certain move okay
this is a doozy
let's move bishop e5 it's a nasty nasty
resource
i have one idea here
that's an alternative
and if this is the move then there is no
way this is a master level problem
um but no it's definitely not the move
the move was queen b2
uh but maybe queen a1 but then he goes
g4
this gets so complicated all right i'm
just gonna go here yep
and they go bishop b5 so i have an idea
here i think that you have to take the
rook
um because if you don't take the rook
what else can we do
let's use the process of elimination uh
well if we go queen b2 he takes on c8 i
don't see an upside to that if we go
queen before he takes on c8
um oh maybe queen before no no no we
gotta take
okay now i think we have to go king f8
if we take on c8 he takes on d7 and he
goes around
okay queen takes c7 okay and i thought
about this and what i think it is
let's break this down and look at his
threats queen e8 is one of his threats
so i think it's king g8 that's what i
actually what it what occurred to me
is the move king j just trying to escape
to h7 this is a hard move to see from a
distance
but it is king g8 we just escaped bishop
d3 i calculated all this now i thought
the key move was rook d3
this is actually what i missed when i
looked at this initially i thought
that black had to play g6 um and maybe
maybe it is g6 i'm not ruling that out
because now i see it's a little bit
more complicated but there there's the
move bishop takes g6 it's a very nasty
move
uh and after f takes g6 he has a
discovery so we're gonna take it now
we're gonna go g6 and
finally the problem is solved it's
listed at 2207.
that was really hard but i'm very happy
that i sort of forced myself to think it
through
i learned a lot what we learn here is
that you can't ignore
any pieces every single piece is
important even the rook on a3 it looks
insignificant
what happened is that my brain had
filtered it out my brain had
you know it grayed out the rook and i
forgot that it existed and it actually
uh was crucial to the correct solution
of this puzzle now let's do one more and
then we'll wrap up there
um here it is white to play and clearly
well white is again down a piece but
he's got a very big attack
against black's king so uh
clear compensation here there's no doubt
about that question how do we go about
um you know finishing the attack well
there's a couple of things that come to
mind using the checks captures threats
formula one is the queen h5 check the
other is knight takes f5
queen h5 track i'm quickly starting to
rule out because it actually helps black
right king f8
the king kind of inches closer to its
defensive cocoon i don't see a purpose
of that knight takes f5 seems completely
overwhelming because
you're removing the defense from the
knight on e4 i mean this just looks
crushing
uh and now just queen f5 yeah so this is
a very simple problem it's it's all
about realizing that
there isn't anything extraordinary here
it's simply a healthy solid attacking
move
problem solved okay well that was that
was very hard and i loved
those problems we had a full variety we
had checkmates we had attacks
uh we had subtle defensive moves we had
long
lines and hopefully you enjoyed this
once again
as you could see it it's not automatic
for me none of these problems are
automatic
uh i have to think them through just
like you do uh and some of them
involve long calculations so a lot of
you will need practice
uh just learning how to visualize lines
and i'll do videos later on
where i show that but for now i think
we'll wrap up
uh for this batch of problems i will
definitely do more of these at different
levels i'll do
sort of a grandmaster uh problem
video where i might do you know only two
or three uh and i might do one at a
somewhat lower level you know 16 1800 so
i'll do various tiers of this
i hope you enjoyed this video uh if you
do like my content consider liking uh or
or subscribing
i greatly appreciate everybody's support
and
i will see you soon uh once again in a
new
video goodbye